- Raja, one skill-based
challenge in the show
is called Lip Sync for your Life.
So could you explain what that is?
- Lip Syncing for your Life is-
- [Kelly] Do you die at
the end? I'm just kidding.
- Yes, you do die.
- The loser does.
- Yeah, Lip Syncing for your Life
is when the two finalists
or the two, I guess, winners
of the challenge...
Is that how it works? It's been so long.
- Either bottoms or tops.
- Either bottoms or tops come together,
and then you duke it out and
then you fight each other.
And then whoever wins the lip sync
is the winner of the night and so on.
- Okay, would you be willing to show us?
- Kelly, I don't know.
- No.
- I don't like attention.
- I'm not like-
- Okay, you don't like attention?
I don't like attention either,
so you're gonna do it to my song.
(all laughing)
So here we go. Let's see it! (laughs)
(audience cheering)
Look at the walk!
♪ Miss on her own ♪
♪ Miss almost grown ♪
♪ Miss never let a man
help her off her thrown ♪
♪ So by keeping her heart protected ♪
♪ She'd never ever feel rejected ♪
♪ Little miss apprehensive ♪
♪ Said ooh, she fell in love ♪
♪ What is this feeling taking over ♪
♪ Thinking no one could open her door ♪
♪ Surprise, it's time ♪
♪ To feel what's real ♪
♪ What happened to miss independent ♪
♪ No longer need to be defensive ♪
♪ Goodbye, old you ♪
♪ When love is true ♪
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
(audience cheering)
(all laughing)